pull 12.7 million pounds that's a fairly
sizable fine it is it's not as much as
the information Commissioner's Office
could have fined them there originally
when they took on notice the
investigation was happening threatened a
27 million pound fine so some mitigation
from Tick Tock has clearly reduced that
but the information Commissioners
officers found several breaches of the
rules uh relating to the data
particularly the use of children's data
and those under 13. now you have to be
13 years or older to use tick tock under
its terms and conditions but it is the
easiest thing in the world to put in a
false date and register the Ico estimate
around 1.4 million under 13s use Tick
Tock by using that simple adjustment of
a date but as a consequence it says Tick
Tock has failed to follow the rules that
it imposes in terms of protecting that
data specifically that when under 13's
data is being used you need parental
consent and Tick Tock did not achieve
that will seek that parental consent
from those uh 1.4 million kids who are
using the site who shouldn't be they
also said they didn't do enough and
don't do enough to explain how data is
used to make it simple to understand
that so that users even those who are
under 13 can make an informed Choice
neither did they do enough to remove
those under 13s from the app which is
widely used by young people they say
tick tock know that there are
potentially millions of under 13s using
the site they also cite uh everybody's
saying this has been brought to the
inter the attention of senior Executives
at Tick Tock in the UK and still nothing
has been done or not enough has been
done to remove those kids from Tick Tock
the information commissioner said they
did not do enough to check who was using
their platform or take sufficient action
to remove the underage children that
were using the platform Tick Tock should
have known better better we have got a
response from Tick Tock it says it
disagrees with the fine that's been
issued by the information commissioner's
office and it is considering its next
steps uh statement reads Tick Tock is a
platform for users aged 13 and over we
invest heavily to keep under 13s off the
platform and our 40 000 strong safety
Team Works Round the Clock to help keep
the platform safe for the community what
those next steps are we'll have to see
but it is just the latest issue to face
the Chinese owned social media app it's
come out of huge pressure politically in
the west because of its Chinese ultimate
Chinese ownership we saw the CEO in
Congress being battered by both sides of
the U.S Congress members on both sides
there is a bill being prepared in
Congress to give the president the power
to ban Tick Tock in the US although
interestingly support has drained away a
little from that it doesn't seem quite
the certainty it was that it would be
banned in the United States but in the
European Union and in the UK they've
been steps to ban the app from
government phones the UK government has
banned the app from phones here and the
Parliamentary estate also you can no
longer have Tick Tock downloaded if you
work in Parliament or indeed in
government on a government device that
is all about the fear that essentially
the data that Tick Tock collects is
accessible by the Chinese State and that
poses a security breach at this fine in
the UK about about it's almost so
perhaps the much more immediate threat
of the action and the impact on children
of an app that's hugely popular and a
great deal of fun when it became when it
Rose to prominence on kids phones but is
perhaps not as clean and safe and
experience certainly the information
commissioner would say as its owners
Tick Tock say